sweaters
scarves
dresses
and even shoes at first glance this all
looks like ordinary knitwear but it
could turn out to be the forerunner of a
real revolution in the clothing industry
the items were manufactured using this
innovative machine knitter8 the world's
first fully automated professional
quality knitting machine in a compact
desktop size it was developed by gerard
rubio originally from spain he now lives
in london rubio hopes his invention will
trigger an earthquake in the fashion
industry we want to democratize clothing
manufacturing with a machine that can be
used by anyone until now clothing
manufacturing has been only in the hands
of a few skilled people and the industry
now we're providing a tool for anyone to
produce their own garments
[Music]
rubio is carrying out his assault on the
textiles industry from this office in
london's east end he met his business
partner triambak saxoner at school
knitter8 software allows users who have
no prior knowledge or experience to
create articles of clothing like a scarf
the user can determine the style and
colors themselves
my vision was to provide a tool that is
really affordable and easy to use for
people to create their own garments at
home garments that are completely
customized
and made
right in the same spot where you're
going to be wearing it
the knitting pattern is transferred to
knitter 8 on a memory card the machine
can process 6 cones of yarn
simultaneously
the carriage pulls the arm through the
feeder to the needles which then make
the stitches
knitter 8 can create garments of a
complexity and quality comparable to
those made by industrial knitting
machines and at a similar speed
so far only this prototype exists the
company raised its seed money through a
crowdfunding campaign
they were aiming for one hundred
thousand dollars but ended up raising
six hundred thousand
there are a lot of meters out there and
we've been told that this is a machine
that they were looking for they were
waiting for
i think it's the first machine in 30
years
the first knitting machine in the last
30 years that has been produced
on a domestic scale
london designer valentina careless was
one of the crowdfunders
she creates her knitwear colorful
dresses and sweaters on a machine that's
almost 100 years old and which is
operated by hand
it takes her two days to complete a
sweater like this one so she can't
produce in large quantities
expanding production in britain would be
too expensive and more affordable
production abroad would be too
complicated that's a common dilemma for
small labels
[Music]
knitter8 would offer an attractive
alternative
[Music]
it would just shorten the time
it would make my
life easier as as you saw when i was
knitting on the machine there is you
know a lifespan at the end of the day i
won't always be able to be knitting i
sometimes have to be in meetings this
way i'll have all the designs figured
out before and i'll be able to get press
go on the machine i can get on with
meetings and and designing which is
essentially what i have to do
for knitter 8's mastermind gerard rubio
designers like valentina corellis are
just a segment of the market he wants to
reach
his vision is for everyone to have an
iterated home so they can make their own
clothing he's been experimenting with
automatic knitting machines for years
his first attempt was open knit in 2013
which was never ready for mass
production
now with nitrate he's taking on the
textiles industry and its lack of
individuality and ready to wear styles
we went
garments that are produced on the other
side of the world
under we don't know which conditions
exactly
and at the same time we're using like
um standardized garments and much better
styles
but the reality is that we are all
different
and
our idea is what we want to provide with
this tool is to empower people
to be more self-sufficient to be more
creative and at the end to be different
this scarf is almost finished it took
niterate three hours to produce the
developers promise high quality and
durability knitter 8 is set to go on
sale next year at a cost of some 7 000
euros
their knitting by hand could become a
thing of the past
you